we're going to create a an omni Channel
retail champion in the UK and we're
going to be number two effectively in
the UK grocery Market uh we're gonna
have a business which is going to have
around 29 billion pound of turnover
we're going to have around 1800 sites
we're going to have a business which
will allow us to extend the Asda brand
to a wider Community than we currently
can do mostly because we're going to
have food service and we're going to
have convenience which we haven't had in
strength in the as the business of the
food it's interesting that you mentioned
nearly 2 000 sites I mean much of the
last decade the debate in groceries was
around online uh food sales something
you know a lot about given your your
pride chairmanship of ocado is the
pendulum swinging back more to
traditional retail than it has done for
for the last 15 years or so
no I think the key word is Omni Channel
today if you're going to be somebody
who's going to compete in this very
competitive world that we compete in
you've got to be able to touch all
places so we have to give customers what
they want where they want how they want
it and we will do that so we will do it
in petrol for court stations we will do
it through convenience we will do it
through our online deliveries we'll do
it in our convenience stores in our
supermarkets in our hypermarkets
um I I read through the press release uh
in detail your comments comments of your
of your very various colleagues
throughout the business what's not
mentioned uh is the deposition of the
company uh is it fair to say that that
was a driving force behind the the deal
as well that it might give the combined
business a better chance to refinance
given that rates have rised and what is
overall a very leveraged business still
the main reason that we have done this
deal is one that we have been looking at
for some time is that when uh we took
over the Asda business some 18 months
two years ago we knew that we had some
massive strengths but we knew we had
some opportunities to build on to that
and that was the convenience part of our
business you'll ever recall that uh some
months ago a while back we acquired 119
sites from the co-op and we've now hired
we've now acquired or will acquire
another number of sites which will allow
us to extend our convenience business uh
now the the when you talk about the
depth position the debt position in
terms of Leverage in as there won't
materially change going forward
but but this uh this will allow you a
benefit of the deal is a hope that
you'll be able to refinance some of the
debt from EG now across the combined
business
well it is true to say that in in doing
this transaction it will uh allow EG to
delever a little bit at some point in
time but the primary purpose of today
and what's Driven today in our strategic
directions today is about driving as the
business when we bought the house the
business back in 2021 we were ambitious
to become for instance number two in the
retail sector in the UK we are currently
number three and we're ambitious to be
number two doing what we're doing today
will allow us to be able to get onto
that roadmap and get and move on in that
direction let's touch a little bit about
the outlook for uh food prices here in
the UK it's been a hot topic of course
do you think the worst of the food price
inflation has been and gone or is there
their higher rates of inflation still to
come
well I'm hopeful that we are at the peak
and then that we will steadily see
decline now but you know we sadly
haven't been able to see the quick
declines that were speculated on earlier
in the year you know it's a very
complicated situation uh causing this
this inflationary situation but I must
say not just asthma all retailers
Wilfred are very very efficient we are a
very efficient industry so in real terms
the cost of food the cost of clothing
and the cost of electronics has come
down over the last 20 30 40 years
largely due to the efficiency of
retailers and governments of any
complexion oh I was a debt of gratitude
and this recent uh you know speculation
over the last couple of days about uh
you know fixing prices it's frankly you
know this is the rather backward looking
it reminds me of a man of a certain age
you know prices of incomes policy that
we used to have in the late 60s let's
touch on that a little bit but it's
clearly an argument was made
successfully made that the oil and gas
Majors uh did deserve to pay a one-off
windfall tax why do food retailers not
deserve either to see price controls or
face a windfall tax
well let's just think it's very simply
look at the look at the profit margins
of food retailers and look at the profit
margins of the energy people over the
last 18 months and the answer will be
very clear you know the retailers make
between three and four percent margin
that's what they make and that's you
know that that if you took to compare
that against margin was made by other
Industries and let's take the energy
industry that's a completely different
that's comparing an apple and a pair
we're in a very efficient industry and
we are very competitive and you know
with a number of outlets that we've got
here now the consumer has got massive
Choice uh and uh and in real terms
fantastic value for money no it's
definitely a fair point low single digit
profit margins uh clearly is is not as
excessive as some businesses I guess the
question uh for for here and this year
ahead when there's clearly cost of
living pressures uh we can't see with
Asda because it's not publicly listed
that the detail that you can see in
other margins would you and do you think
your colleagues at other big food
retailers pledge not to increase that
margin during this this tricky time for
consumers
we've all went in look at the profit
results that were produced by our
competitors and ourselves most
ly trailers our grocery retailers
profits over the last year have gone
backwards whether you're talking about
Tesco whether you're talking about
Sainsbury's whether you're talking about
Asda they've all gone backwards we as an
industry have lent in and done some very
very good work in making sure our
customers get great prices we had an
operation well ahead of the government's
proposal last week about locking prices
down which we call dropped a lot where
we fixed prices for nearly a year at the
beginning of 2022. so we're very active
in making sure we sell close to stay
close to our customers and give them the
deals that they expect but it's tough
because if you look at commodity prices
as they come through for all the reasons
we know they've been going up whether
it's raw material prices whether average
oil whether it's wheat whether it's a
butter fat you know we've seen massive
increases your question earlier was have
we reached the peak of that I would hope
so and you know going forward into 2024
let's hope that we reach better times
I'm just touching on fuel retail prices
uh petrol prices as well something that
of course you're heavily involved with
uh too somewhat in in the eye of the
storm here in terms of your exposures
the CMA recently reported that at least
one supermarket has significantly
increased its internal forward-looking
margin targets over this period though
speculation they they were referring to
you is it unfair though to look at Asda
and EG's relative price increases of
fuel as opposed to the absolute because
on absolute levels you're fairly low and
you're starting from a point where prior
owners Walmart the US owners wanted to
drive footfall into the stores and make
a loss with fuel retail well just talk
us through some some of your current
pricing and thinking on that
we wear and have been for many years the
price leader amongst the big four
supermarkets we are currently the price
leader amongst the four supermarkets we
are committed to be the price leader
amongst the four supermarkets full stop
fair enough so that that might though
mean ongoing percentage increases but in
absolute levels you you'll uh you'll
maintain your your price leadership
well you won't be the cheapest amongst
the Big Four
fair enough um so so just uh coming back
to the the bigger picture uh Lord rose
do you understand the predicament the
government faces when it has to weigh up
whether to impose price controls whether
it has to weigh up to impose windfall
taxes or would it be a terrible error
for the long-term future of British
business if the government pushed
further than it has done already more
than just rhetoric uh into the food
retail space to try and uh impose some
price limits
listen I'm not an economist but I'm a
businessman I've been in business for 50
years you can't interfere with Market
forces at the end of the day you have to
trust us as retailers to give our
consumers the best deals our customers
are very Savvy they're very smart they
know that we're working hard to do
things on their behalf we will continue
to do so intervention it always brings
in unintended consequences and
personally I would not recommend it